>> Pete: WELCOME BACK NEW DATA
OUT THIS WEEK IS CONFIRMING WHAT
WE DO ALL ALONG.
SCHOOL CLOCKDOWNS DEVASTATING
IMPACT ON OUR KID'S EDUCATION.
FEDERAL TESTING NUMBERS FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION SHOW
THAT OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS,
READING AND MATH SCORES HAVE
SUFFERED THE STEEPEST DECLINE WE
HAVE SEEN IN DECADES.
LOOK AT THIS.
THE AVERAGE SCORES FOR FOURTH
GRADERS HAVE DROPPED 5 POINTS IN
READING.
AND 7 POINTS IN MATH SINCE THE
START OF COVID-19.
AND THE LOCKDOWN.
THIS IS THE BIGGEST DECREASE WE
HAVE SEEN IN READING IN 30 YEARS
AND IT'S THE DEEPEST YEAR OVER
YEAR DECLINE IN MATH SCORES ON
RECORD.
THESE NUMBERS ARE INDEED
ALARMING.
BUT THEY ARE PART OF AN EVEN
MORE ALARMING TREND.
EFFICIENCY IN READING AND MATH
THEY HAVE BEEN ON A DOWNWARD
SLIDE FOR BETTER PART OF A
DECADE AND COVID MADE IT WORSE.
SCHOOL LOCKDOWN CRUSHED
STUDENTS' ABILITY TO LEARN.
AND NO ONE HAD A BIGGER ROLE IN
KEEPING SCHOOLS CLOSED THAN THE
PRESIDENT OF THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS, RANDY
WEINGARTEN.
SHE FOUND-SHE FOUGHT TOOTH AND
NAIL FOR KIDS AND TEACHERS TO
STAY AT HOME AS LONG AS
POSSIBLE.
AND NOW, SHE IS REWRITING
HISTORY.
>> THE EFFECTS OF THAT
DISRUPTION.
DO YOU HAVE ANY REGRETS FOR NOT
ADVOCATING IN A MORE STRONG
FASHION FOR A FASTER RETURN TO
IN PERSON LEARNING?
>> SO THIS IS WHERE I'M GOING TO
REALLY DISAGREE WITH YOU.
I MEAN, I WAS -- I PERSONALLY I
HAVE BEEN PUSHING FOR THE RETURN
TO IN PERSON LEARNING SINCE
APRIL OF 2020.
COULD WE OVERCOME ALL THE FEAR?
I WISH WE COULD HAVE.
BUT I DON'T THINK IT'S ANYBODY'S
FAULT THAT WE DIDN'T UNDERSTAND
WHAT WAS GOING ON IN TERMS OF
SCHOOL.
>> Pete: APRIL OF 2020?
THAT'S A FLAT OUT LIE.
AND LUCKY FOR US, WE HAVE THE
TAPE TO PROVE IT RANDY AND HER
TEACHER UNION FRIENDS HAD ZERO
INTEREST IN RETURNING TO THE
CLASSROOM.
>> WE HAVE AN OBLIGATION TO MAKE
REMOTE BETTER BECAUSE UNTIL WE
CAN REALLY DECREASE COMMUNITY
SPREAD THROUGHOUT THE UNITED
STATES, DISTANCE LEARNING AND
DISTANCE WORKING IS GOING TO BE
A FACT OF LIFE.
>> THE REASON WE RAISE THE ISSUE
ABOUT AS A LAST RESORT ON A
LOCAL BASIS, A SAFETY STRIKE
ACTION IS BECAUSE WE ARE REALLY
CONCERNED AS SCHOOLS START
OPENING IN AUGUST THAT YOU GOT
THE DENIERS AND YOU HAVE GOT THE
MAC THINKING.
>> WE KNOW PEOPLE NEED IN PERSON
LEARNING AND REMOTE INSTRUCTION
IS NO SUBSTITUTE FOR IT BUT IT
HAS TO BE SAFE!
>> Pete: SHE SAID SHE HAS BEEN
FIGHTING FOR IT SINCE APRIL OF
2020.
ALL OF THOSE COLLISION ARE FROM
JULY AND AUGUST OF 2020 THEY SAY
THEY ARE ABOUT PROTECTING THE
KIDS.
IF THESE PEOPLE WANTED TO MAKE
SCHOOLS SAFER WHO KIDS COULD
RETURN TO THE CLASSROOM THEY
WOULD HAVE ACTUALLY SPENT, I
DON'T KNOW, THE MONEY DESIGNATED
FOR COVID CHANGES IN SCHOOLS TO
MAKE IT EASIER TO REOPEN?
I MEAN, ISN'T THAT WHAT THEY SAY
THEY WANTED ALL ALONG?
MORE MONEY?
WELL, GET THIS, OF THE
122 BILLION IN FEDERAL MONEY SET
ASIDE FOR SCHOOLS, BARELY OVER
15 BILLION HAS BEEN SPENT.
THAT MEANS ALMOST 90% OF THE
COVID MONEY IS UNTOUCHED.
I'M SURE THEY WILL SPEND THE
REMAINING 100 BILLION VERY
WISELY.
HOW MANY DIVERSITY, EQUITY AND
INCLUSION ADVISERS AND INVESTORS
CAN YOU HIRE FOR THAT?
AND IT GETS WORSE.
THEY ARE NOT TAKING ANY
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE DAMAGE
THEY HAVE CAUSED.
INSTEAD, THEY ARE PASSING THE
BLAME ON TO SOMEBODY ELSE, AND
YOU KNOW WHO THEY ARE BLAMING.
HERE IS WHAT EDUCATION SECRETARY
MIGUEL CARDONA SAID THIS WEEK
AND I QUOTE:  TODAY'S DATA
CONFIRMED THE SIGNIFICANT IMPACT
THE PRIOR ADMINISTRATION'S
MISMANAGEMENT OF THE PANDEMIC
HAS HAD ON OUR CHILDREN'S
PROGRESS AND ACADEMIC
WELL-BEING.
WE MUST REPAIR THE DAMAGE DONE
BY ORANGE MAN BAD DONALD TRUMP'S
MISMANAGEMENT OF THE PANDEMIC
AND WE WILL.
WHAT WORLD ARE THESE PEOPLE
LIVING IN?
DONALD TRUMP SAID OVER AND OVER
AGAIN OPEN THE SCHOOL.
>> GOT TO GO TO SCHOOL.
WE HAVE GOT TO OPEN UP.
WE HAVE GOT TO OPEN UP OUR
SCHOOLS AND OPEN UP OUR
BUSINESSES.
>> I WANT TO SAY GET OPEN IN THE
FALL.
WE WANT YOUR SCHOOLS OPEN.
>> CHILDREN ARE AT THE LOWEST
RISK OF ANY AGE GROUP FROM
VIRUS.
INDEFINITE SCHOOL CLOSURES WILL
INFLICT LASTING HARM TO OUR
NATION'S CHILDREN.
>> Pete: HE SAID WHAT WE KNEW
KIDS AT THE LOWEST RISK.
SURPRISE, SURPRISE, DONALD TRUMP
WAS RIGHT ALL ALONG.
WHEN WE LOOK AT THE BIG PICTURE,
THE DAMAGE CAUSED BY SCHOOL
LOCKDOWNS IS JUST A BIG PIECE OF
THE PUZZLE.
THE SLOW MOTION IMPLOSION OF OUR
EDUCATION SYSTEM IS BUILDING FOR
DECADES.
WE ARE JUST NOW NOTICING.
IN MY BOOK I CALLED IT THE COVID
1619 MOMENT.
PARENTS SEEING WHAT THEIR KIDS
WERE BEING TAUGHT IN THEIR ZOOM
CLASSROOMS IT BECAME IMPOSSIBLE
TO IGNORE.
PUBLIC SCHOOLS MORE ACCURATELY
CALLED GOVERNMENT SCHOOLS ARE NO
OLONGER FOCUSING ON TEACHING THE
KIDS THE ESSENTIALS, READING,
WRITING, ARITHMETIC, HISTORY,
CIVICS, HOWEVER YOU SAY
ARITHMETIC.
POISONING YOUNG MINDS WITH SEX
ED SHEAR INDOCTRINATION RICH
STATES POOR STATES.
GOVERNMENT SCHOOLS AND PRIVATE
SCHOOLS.
IT'S SERIOUS STUFF.
YOU MIGHT SAY IT'S A THREAT TO
OUR REPUBLIC YOU CAN'T KEEP A
COUNTRY IF YOU ARE TEACHING KIDS
TO HATE THAT COUNTRY.
THE AFFECTIONS AND AFFILIATIONS
OF OUR KIDS ARE THE TARGET OF
THE LEFT AND NOW THOSE SAME KIDS
CAN'T EVEN READ RACHEL
CAMPOS-DUFFY IS MY CO-HOST ON
"FOX & FRIENDS WEEKEND" AND CAN
A ROLLE MARK WITS COLUMNIST ON
"THE NEW YORK POST."
RACHEL, SOUND OFF.
THEY ARE ADMITTING KIDS ARE
FALLING BEHIND BUT IT'S DONALD
TRUMP'S FAULT.
>> YEAH.
THEY DO NOT GET TO GET AWAY WITH
GAS LIGHTING US ON THIS.
>> FAUCI BIDEN, WOLVES, REANELD
WEINGARTEN.
ALL OF THEM FOUGHT TO SHUT DOWN
OUR SCHOOLS.
NOT ONLY SHUT DOWN OUR PUBLIC
SCHOOLS BUT PRIVATE SCHOOLS THE
CATHOLIC SCHOOLS.
THEY TRIED TO GET THEM TO SHUT
DOWN BECAUSE THEY COULDN'T HAVE
THEM OPEN PROVING THAT NO KIDS
CATHOLIC SCHOOLS PROVED THAT YOU
COULD DO IT BY THE WAY KEEP THE
SCHOOLS OPEN.
NO ONE IS GOING TO DIE.
BY THE WAY, THEY DIDN'T NEED ALL
THOSE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS THAT
YOU TALKED ABOUT THAT ARE NOW
GOING TO GO TO DIVERSITY AND CRT
PROGRAMS AND TRANSGENDER
PROGRAMS IN OUR SCHOOL.
THEY DIDN'T NEED THAT DO YOU
KNOW WHO DID STAY OPEN, PETE?
THE CHINESE.
195 MILLION CHINESE STUDENTS
WENT RIGHT BACK TO SCHOOL IN THE
FALL WHEN THEY WERE SHUTTING
DOWN OUR SCHOOLS AND, BOY, THE
CHINESE LOVE THIS OUR KIDS GOT,
YOU KNOW, THEIR SCORES WENT
DOWN.
THEY GOT LAZIER, THEY GOT
DEPRESSED, THEY GOT SUICIDAL,
THEY GOT FATTER BECAUSE
CHILDHOOD OBESITY WENT UP WHEN
YOU CLOSED DOWN THE SCHOOLS AND
LOCKED OUR KIDS UP.
ALL OF THIS, YOU COULDN'T --
CHAIRMAN XI COULDN'T HAVE
THOUGHT OF A BETTER PLAN TO
UNDERMINE OUR FUTURE THESE
SCORES ARE.
>> THEY TURNED THE VIRUS OVER TO
US IT WAS PART OF THEIR PLAN.
ARE THEY THIS CYNICAL OR DO THEY
REALLY BELIEVE WHAT THEY ARE
SAYING HERE, THE DEMOCRATS?
>> I THINK THEY ARE TRYING TO
ABSOLUTELY REWRITE HISTORY.
THE TIMELINE IS SO IMPORTANT.
I LOVE THAT YOU CALLED OUT RANDI
WEINGARTEN FOR WANTING TO KEEP
SCHOOLS CLOSED IN 2020 IMPORTANT
TO NOTE SHE WANTED TO KEEP THEM
CLOSED IN 2021 ALSO.
IT WASN'T JUST HER.
SECRETARY CARDONENA, JOE BIDEN,
TONS OF GOVERNORS, TONS ON THE
LEFT WANTED TO KEEP SCHOOLS
CLOSED FOR SEPTEMBER OF 2021.
WHEN GOVERNOR DESANTIS MY
GOVERNOR IN FLORIDA WAS HEADING
TOWARDS REOPENING SCHOOLS.
ALL THE HEADLINES SAID FLORIDA
SCHOOLS OPEN AS K THROUGH CLIMB.
SPECIFIC MOTION TO STOP FLORIDA
FROM OPENING SCHOOLS.
THEY KEPT SCHOOLS OPEN AND
PROVED IT WAS POSSIBLE.
ALL OF THESE DEMOCRATS WANT TO
PRETEND THEY WEREN'T INVOLVED IN
THIS TRAGEDY THAT WE ARE LIVING
THROUGH RIGHT NOW AND THIS
TRAVESTY WITH THESE SCORES.
ABSOLUTELY AT THEIR FEET AND
RANDI WEINGARTEN IS NUMBER ONE
PERSON THAT CAUSED THIS.
>> Pete: WE KNEW EVEN THEY KIDS
WERE NOT THE ONES EFFECTED.
NUMBER ONE DO VOTERS REMEMBER
THIS.
>> OF COURSE THEY DO.
THIS IS -- YOU TALK ABOUT THIS
AWAKENING, 161 MOMENT THAT YOU
TALKED ABOUT, IT'S NOT JUST
WHAT, YOU KNOW, WAS -- THEY WERE
TEACHING OUR CHILDREN, BUT THE
WAY THEY WANTED TO TORTURE OUR
CHILDREN, THE PARENTS WHO HAD TO
FIGHT TO KEEP THE SCHOOLS OPEN,
TO TAKE THE MASKS OFF.
PARENTS ARE NOT GOING TO FORGET
THIS THEY DON'T GET TO GET AWAY
WITH THIS.
WE CERTAINLY SHOULD KEEP
REPLAYING THESE CLIPS AS YOU
JUST HAVE DONE, PETE, BECAUSE,
SOMETIMES, THEY WANTS TO REWRITE
HISTORY.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO LET THEM DO
IT THIS TIME.
>> Pete: CAN A ROLLE, YOU MADE
THE MOVE SAY HEY WE WILL GO TO
FLORIDA WHERE